It may surprise you to know that attention is like a muscle,...
...like a muscle in the arm,...
...and that there are exercises, mental exercises that improve attention,...
...that strengthen the brain circuitry for attention...
...just like you'd go to the gym and you'd do some reps on a Cybex machine...
...and get a stronger tricep.
These exercises are very simple but very effective.
The social emotional learning curricula have many that are developmentally appropriate...
...so that you teach the same lesson in different ways as children's cognitive abilities...
...expand with brain growth and as they go through the grades.
One of the most effective is something called "The Stoplight."
It's a poster on the wall of a classroom.
It says, "When you're upset, remember the stoplight."
Red light: stop, calm down, think before you act.
Yellow light: think of a range of different things you could do now...
...and what the outcome would be.
Green light: pick the best one and try it out.
It's a highly effective method.